[Musique]
elle est impressionnante avec son
clocher qui surplombe le fleuve
Saint-Laurent impossible de passer à
côté de la chapelle Notre-Dame de Bon
Secours sans la remarquer c'est la plus
ancienne construite à Montréal elle
célèbre 250 ans d'existence cette année
mais elle abrite en réalité des milliers
d'années d'histoire donc là ici on a les
vestiges de la palissade de Montréal
c'est un site unique parce que les
vestiges qu'on retrouve ici sous la
chapelle ça témoigne de 2400 ans
d'histoire humaine sans interruption
fondée en 1655 la chapelle a été
détruite dans un incendie puis
reconstruite résultat ce qui se trouve
sous la structure et longtemps resté
intouché
archéologiques menées au milieu des
années 90 ont permis de trouver les
fondations de la toute première chapelle
ainsi que des traces d'activité
autochtones vieilles de 2000 ans avec la
foule de détails de vestige qu'on
retrouve ici
écoutez on est capable de reconstruire
des pannes d'histoire l'objectif
s'assurer de conserver ses précieuses
informations une grande opération de
numérisation a donc été lancé donc ici
on a le chemin Saint-François des
maquettes semblables à celle-ci
permettront d'avoir un plan extrêmement
précis de l'intérieur mais aussi de
l'extérieur de la chapelle l'idée de la
numérisation c'était de nous donner une
photo exacte et identique de ce qu'est
la chapelle avoir au micro millimètre
près ce qu'elle est ce qu'elle
représente donc pour nous permettre de
l'entretenir les équipes devraient
terminer la numérisation de l'intérieur
de la chapelle cet automne après quoi il
s'attaqueront à l'extérieur
et les responsables du site historique
voix grand ils veulent en faire profiter
les visiteurs l'idée à court terme c'est
de pouvoir permettre aux gens de prendre
au téléphone de pouvoir zoomer sur une
partie imaginez l'odoratrice ici de
pouvoir vous asseoir dans un bain de la
chapelle et d'admirer les tableaux de
Meloche et là je vous permets avec votre
téléphone de pouvoir zoomer et d'aller
voir les détails du tableau de pouvoir
scruter la signature de pouvoir voir le
coup de pinceau c'est infini comme
possibilité de ce qu'on de ce qu'on peut
faire on est le petit joyau et bijou
méconnu de Montréal il faut que les gens
nous redécouvrent et ils insistent la
chapelle Notre-Dame de Bon Secours est
beaucoup plus qu'un lieu de culte c'est
aussi un site archéologique et un
important témoin de l'histoire Montréal
à l'aise ici qui me permettra du Canada
Montréal